we've got about 12 billion of common
stocks since the election now that well
that's that's unless it's in my mind
which ones I pick now the guys that
worked with me the two fellows they
probably bought a little bit or so a
little bit too but but those are just
those are ideas that I've either
commented from a different slant in some
way or whatever it may be good Airlines
one of those well it was showing that I
won't tell you anything we're selling
out it was show it on September 30th
that we own some airlines some stocks so
why did you do that well I thought I
won't get into it but it was it was in
large part by decision no joke is as you
know absolutely had you become a million
I start as a busy nearby airline there's
no there's no question that it's been a
graveyard for a lot of hahaha a lot of
money but transportation has been
something you know then but they're not
related the railroads and Airlines are
not related at all they're different
kinds of businesses you can't can't move
the track of planes around cool and and
you can't go into it I mean airlines
attract people just just by there's a
certain romance to it like Hollywood
does or something and and so you can
actually go into the business and more
than a hundred Airlines have gone broke
in on the last 20 or 25 years or
something like that so it it's a
different sort of business how is
knowing Bill changed or influenced or
enhanced your sense of the way the world
works well I learned from him
you know I like to learn from all
friends and Bill happens if you have a
particularly good source but but that's
that's the fun of having friends Charlie
you know I I don't think I would be hard
for me to be a friend with anyone that I
don't learn something from under the
public I've got a board with me who's
that guy talking about stocks well I see
immense amount I you know I he wrote an
article for Fortune magazine that I read
before I met him about that it's not
necessarily good idea to leave large
sums to your children so that was pretty
fundamental and I remember reading that
and I I was convinced that that was
right man
Wow now you have to think of how to have
a give it away
I also remember Warren showing me his
calendar and I love you know I had every
minute packed and I thought that was the
only way you could do things and you
know the fact that he is so careful
about yesterday's that there's nothing
on that there's nothing on solution and
this is a very high-tech be careful you
might not understand I'm gonna hold
another thing this is the week of April
of which there are only three entries
for a week yeah they'll be for maybe
baby file tax so that to me what did not
to crowd yourself too much and give
yourself an you read and think and write
that you control your time and that
sitting and thinking I may be much
higher priority than a normal CEO who
you know there's all this demand and you
feel like you need to go and see all
these people it's not a proxy of your
seriousness that you filled every minute
in your schedule and I'm going to want
to want your time and it's the only
thing you can't buy I mean I buy
anything I want
basically but I can't buy time and so to
have time is the most precious thing you
can have it I better be careful with it
okay there's no way I will be able to
buy more time and living in Omaha makes
that easy that makes it a lot easier I
450 whatever things outfit is it fits
well than for four years I spent five
minutes going each way now just imagine
that was a half an hour each way you
know I know the words do a lot more
songs and that's about it
it adds up Duncan yeah it really has to
know if you're doing an hour a day
difference coming and going and you know
yes that's two and a half percent of the
person's workweek yeah that means 40
years you're talking about a year
do you agree politically on almost
everything you know a general sense that
you've got to keep the economy
greater output and that you have to
allocate it in a fair way yeah that that
basic framework we see very much the
same do both you believe we can achieve
a four percent growth rate that's pretty
high
pretty much but it actually just by 2016
I think the last quarter was like 1.6 or
some Charlie a 2 percent growth rate if
we have a little less than 1 percent
population growth which we probably will
in one generation 25 years now people
have kids a little later we'll add
19,000 per capita family of four 76002
real GDP so there will be 70 family of
four on average there would be 76,000
more stuff per family of four in one
generation I mean we are going to have
more and the golden goose is going to
keep laying more golden eggs
I mean and we've got a wonderful system
well but but there are certain things it
could could get in the way of that 2
percent I think a little bit no you do 2
percent and 2 percent will produce
miracles